on the hunt for a precious
commodity and finally after hours of
searching through woodlands in Northern
Italy A Stroke of
Luck it may look like little more than a
mudcake stone but for this well-trained
Italian pointer the unmistakable smell
gives it away this is the Italian tatuo
biano the Truffle Hunter's most
treasured prize and it's a delicacy that
in recent weeks has become a lot more
affordable able thanks to a dramatic
fall in prices heavy summer rains around
the town of Alba have led to a roughly
30% increase in the number of tartufo
biano truffles compared to the same time
last
year 100 G of this culinary gold
currently comes in at around
€220 that's down from
€350 in 2013 and €500 in
2012 a cheaper white truffle means more
buyers cut pric gourmet meals and a jump
in visitor numbers to the Region's
annual
markets the local economy is very
dependent on the Truffle business we
calculate that for every Euro spent on a
truffle meal tourists spend at least 20
more Euros in the area so the real
income for us comes from tourism not
just truffle sales Italy's truffle
Hunters now hope a push beyond their
traditional markets will be another
boost to demand for this sorta
delicacy
Emerging Markets like Brazil China India
and Vietnam will become very interesting
for us in a few years they'll soon see
white truffle in the same light as they
now see
kaviar in the meantime tartufo lovers
here in Alba are making the most of
their cheaper
treat